Virginia Governor Ralph Northam insists
he will not resign over erases yearbook
photo in an interview you'll see only on
CBS news today the Democrat says he will
do everything he can to regain
Virginia's trust that photograph from
his 1984 medical spear at medical school
yearbook rather surfaced 10 days ago
Northam has apologized repeatedly and
later said he was not in that image in a
Washington Post poll over the weekend 73
percent of Virginians said they did not
believe his explanation for the photo 53
percent said they accept his apology
there's more of our conversation with
the governor I marvel that you're still
standing when so many people have said
you've got to go and you got to go now
I'm thinking either he's got a lot of
confidence or he's just a little crazy
well I know in my heart Who I am and I
know what I can do and Virginia right
now I need to leader this strong that
has courage and that can take us to the
next level one and I can do that you
might have to convince people that
you're still the right leader for this
job you have a lot to do I have a lot of
work to do but I will do everything that
I can to regain Virginia's trust
starting with a press conference nine
days ago he says to set the record
straight denying the man in that racist
photo was him I believe then and now
that I am NOT either of the people in
that photo so take us in the process of
you realize Oh houston we have a problem
That's not me
take us behind the scenes of discussions
that you and your staff and your wife
had about now we're going to go in front
of the cameras and say it isn't me
Saturday was a very busy day I did talk
to my wife my close colleagues and I I
just made the decision that we need to
clarify this but was there some concern
with people saying governor now you're
going to really look crazy well I've
always been a transparent person and I
just thought it was important to let
people know that that wasn't me that's
not who I was at that time
and it's certainly not who I am now
after 35 years of service to to this
country in my Commonwealth so after
Saturday the drumbeat started beating
immediately about he needs to go he
needs to go by people in your own party
by some of the top Democratic leaders in
the country by some of your constituents
who were protesting outside your home
and after that happened you thought what
I thought first of all I've heard a lot
of people not only in in Virginia but in
this country but I also know that I was
elected to be the governor of Virginia
people had faith and confidence in me
and we've had a great first year we've
expanded health care to over 400,000
we've dealt with criminal justice reform
we've raised and felony larceny know
your your history of work is good your
history of work is good but I do want to
make sure that we focus on this because
I think that this is really important to
clarify your position yeah and why you
think you still deserve this job when so
many people are calling for you to step
down well again we we have worked very
hard right now Virginia needs someone
that can heal Virginia also needs
someone who is strong who has empathy
who has courage and who has a moral
compass and that's why I'm not going
anywhere you know the other thing that
struck people in the news conference is
when you were talking about Michael
Jackson and you said you know because
many people know it's hard to remove
shoe polish from your face and I'm
thinking a how do you know that yeah
because it implies that you certainly
put shoe polish on your face on more
than one occasion how do you know that
it's difficult to remove well I didn't
know that when I dressed up as as
Michael Jackson I put some shoe polish
on my cheeks on both sides you also are
not you but folks need to know that I
went to military school Military College
for four years I polished my shoes
almost every day we did that with what
we call a spit shine rags a very thin
piece of cloth and the shoe polish yes
and the shoe polish goes through that
cloth and it gets on your finger of my
finger and it's very difficult to remove
so that that's why I know she polishes
so that's what you were referring to
that's correct
from the very beginning you said you
were not stepping down but the story has
certainly changed are there any
circumstances that you would step down
well I'm prepared right now to move
forward I don't have any plans to resign
and I think we have a unique opportunity
to make impactful changes wouldn't you
have preferred to have this unique
opportunity another way I would but I
kind again I really do believe that
things happen for a reason and I'm a
faithful person and there is a reason I
believe that this happened and happened
to you it did and what do you think that
reason is that we are in a position to
to learn I will focus on race and equity
that's something that for the next three
years is going to be my commitment to
Virginia and I really think we can make
impactful changes well and part of our
interview with the governor that aired
yesterday he used the term indentured
servants instead of slaves to refer to
the African captives who arrived in
Virginia back in 1619 in a statement he
told he told us this morning that during
a recent event at Fort Monroe I spoke
about the arrival of the first Africans
in Virginia and refer to them in my
remarks as enslaved an historian advised
me that the use of indentured was more
historically accurate
the fact is I'm still learning and
committed to getting it right you know I
have to say when I was talking to him I
did not feel that he was in he was
disingenuous or that he was trying to
spin a story he knows that he has a lot
of questions to answer you know that
he's getting hammered for those
statements about saying indentured and I
think he talked to an historian and
that's what he was told that that was a
more historically accurate way to say it
but you know when he said that you know
it made me wince a little bit because
the bottom line is it's still slavery
and we all agree on that including the
governor he agrees with that - yeah
indentured servitude is different than
slaves yes much different which is that
many Europeans came to this country
saying they would work for seven years
and that would be would be free that is
different than what was enacted into law
in Virginia in 1640 but she was the
slavery laws maybe this is an
opportunity for history teachers across
the country you need another course